[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum Bob Odenkirk is coming
on it's an intro God's sakes just blow
your ear drums out sorry some some
somebody left a comment once and they
were like um yeah I almost turned it off
because I didn't see Bob I didn't see
your guest I mean have you ever heard of
an introduction I guess I'm not boring
huh I didn't want to see me for whatever
Ryan's not here again so I'm doing this
all by my lonesome but he is doing
editing massive amounts of editing Bob
Odenkirk one which is coming up right
now was pretty fantastic and it got long
because I was just like holy crap it's
such a it's such a great conversation we
talked about Chris Farley we talked
about because he wrote land you know van
down by the river he wrote or co-wrote
worked with Chris as well
that sketch which is to me there's
nobody funnier than Chris Farley and
that sketch is one of the funniest
sketches I've ever seen and we talk
about that a lot I think he he enjoyed
it I was hoping he would because you
never know he's a car we're talking
about so much about the past well I
really truly love Bob Odenkirk on this
on the show he he was just so open and
and sweet and we've talked a lot about
everything he just seemed you know it is
he seemed interested interested in me
interested in my house interested in in
life you know I know a lot I don't know
one person who doesn't like Bob Odenkirk
he's been working his ass off his whole
life and you know Saul obviously is you
know or Breaking Bad was his big break
being bad and then I better call Saul
which is on now and is getting better
and better and better and I have a lot
of catching up to do to be honest with
you sorry Bob if you're listening to
this but anyway I'm not gonna get into
anything else I hope you guys are all
well I hope you subscribe to the podcast
if you're not please support us we all
do this for free obviously we're doing
my line I pay people to help me with
this but so you just watching listening
sending to your friends getting them to
subscribe writing reviews it just really
helps in the scheme of things so I thank
you dearly for that I just started a
series called the kingdom pretty rad on
Netflix I subtitle it my friend Harlan
decided to overdub it in English which I
don't know how he does that drives me
crazy
livvie called the platform I think it
was a Netflix may be really good you
know I love my horror and
anyway Camp Rosie be on the lookout for
it's coming out
Halloween we're gonna be doing camp
Rosie the links will come out soon they
will tickets will sell out it's two days
at a summer camp for Halloween camp
Rosie camp Rosie and patreon thank you
so much to all my patreon it's just
incredible the large amount of people
fans friends now it's a community that
have joined patreon to support the
podcast and we do all sorts of fun stuff
just go to patreon patreon com
there's so many perks so if you're a fan
of the podcast you could join and you
get messages from me when you join and
there's just a bunch of good stuff you
want to check that out you get a bunch
of extra bonus stuff if I see a bunch of
extra sheets Louise you know something
that good happen that I want to throw
out there because you know obviously
there's a lot of bad but there's a lot
of good too
my grandfather passed away November 28th
my brother's birthday on Thanksgiving
and you know he was my best friend I
loved her deeply dearly everyone did and
you know it's really tough for my
grandmother and April 8th was his would
have been his 94th birthday and it was
tough for my grandma she's quarantined
so we're all quarantined if you're doing
the right thing and my cousin Jill his
granddaughter Jill my husband gave birth
to a little boy and named him jack
Irving and I just thought that was
really cool
on herbs birthday that happens
thought that was a damn good thing damn
good thing stay tuned afterwards I'm
gonna read a couple of letters from fans
and what they think of the show and I
haven't even read some of them yet but I
do read them and thank you for just
being you sound like mr. Rogers
let's get inside of Bob Odenkirk it's my
point of view you're listening to inside
of you with Michael Rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
so my recording he's recording and
that's recording over there oh yeah yeah
Ryan good yeah it's great yeah so anyway
you're looking around yeah yeah you have
so much
Navi Lea I think it's pretty damn cool I
mean like I said I don't collect stuff I
don't keep anything that you were
looking at my stuff beforehand you said
that one of the reasons I don't is
literally because people like you exist
so I don't need to because instead of me
having all this stuff you have it and I
can just somehow find my way to your
place once in a while and get to look at
it and go wow do you get to leave and
you have to take care of it do you not
have one thing at your house or do you
have one thing that you're like if I met
this actor if I worked with this guy
there's one thing I just want something
the one thing what if it was Robert De
Niro if you worked with De Niro no I sat
next to him at the Saturday Night Live
45th anniversary that he'd know who you
were no did you say something to him I
looked at I mean he looked at me and
then I didn't bother did he give you
like a the breath he seemed in his own
world he was with his wife I think I
took her seat for my bit and that's why
we interacted a little bit four years in
you had yeah I am a line or something I
think it was during any Murphy's thing I
there was like a line I had and it was
right next to Robert De Niro yes I was
sitting next to him or his wife
somebody had to move a seat so I could
sit there for my bit so they could get
me on camera and then my seat was behind
a row a little ways up on the same row
as Bill O'Reilly and lots everybody was
famous in that room but you say well
Riley and I'm like why is he here what
is he doing what are you doing here
he likes comedy yeah I'll bet you said
something that you love right wingers
attempts at comedy it's always [ __ ]
great these guys on Fox News like Greg
got
oh my god it's such a sweat to watch him
try to but you do watch it you watch
John I don't I don't go there but when
it's on I'm like all of this guys trying
to be funny and I just you get to sweat
like crazy and think ah it's I've hard
that's what makes you happy
watching people it's kind it's always an
angry laugh it's never a fun sweet or
low level or his yes his attempt at
humor and I agree that if somebody were
to say well a lot of Bob a lot of the
comi you did was pretty harsh stuff
you're right right but there was more of
a joy to it and a silliness and the
lightness but a lot of right-wingers
when they try to be funny it's only
angry it's only just anger coming out
and couch does isn't this funny we're
making fun and it's got such
anger in it and you can just see it's
not hidden at all and you like that well
I like how hard they have to work to
Chand how much it's just watching
someone strive so overtly so clearly
striving there's the world just going
for it
no they are they have tons of cares in
the world they have no they have no they
can't relax at all because everything
Wow geez I'm overanalyzing it to you
maybe but how many people would know I
think writers would know exactly what I
mean like what right-wingers would you
say now we're going to analyze I said
what right-wingers do you think I really
make this too political or because I
don't piss funny like I know you know
who's real conservative was a friend of
yours who's a you know a very
conservative who is funny isn't Norma
Donald kind of conservative is a I think
he's really funny she's brilliant it's
one of the funniest guys ever
I always thought Nick DiPaolo was pretty
damn funny who's Nick DiPaolo I should
use a comic and New York comic yeah very
conservative and he is very conservative
but you find him funny he can be damn
funny
yeah you said something in an interview
that you were like famous people still
make you nervous I don't know if you
were kidding around because I kind of
had that feeling I get that feeling so I
can when I see something interview like
that this little nuance of like yeah I
get nervous I always do you really get
nervous around big stars
you know I've refined my sense of my own
anxiety a little bit because some people
like I think it has more to do with
their kind of like the way they approach
the world and what you who you think
you're interacting with if you if you
think the person is on the same
wavelength as you then no so like I did
a movie called the post and it was
I was very very awkward around Stephen
who's such a nice person
Stephen Spielberg who directed it and
that's what Meryl Streep and yeah and
and also Tom Hanks who I've known for a
long long time and I'm nervous around
them extremely nervous they didn't know
that I think they could sense it sure
what is it about what how would you
describe yourself if somebody was
watching you at last he read something
today that made me gave me clarity on it
and it said something to me it was sure
there's a line from something in an
article you don't recruit Spielberg if
you aren't looking for a product with
heart one that has optimism instead of
cynicism at its core and that's true
and I think I have cynicism at my core
and so when I'm around people who don't
see the world that way
it's iy2 is hard I get more nervous I I
don't feel like I can relax and just say
anything and they'll understand the the
layer of cynical critique that is just a
part of how I look at the world and then
then I have to be very careful around
them it's like being around an aunt and
uncle at a wedding and they go what tell
me about this Breaking Bad and you going
well yeah it's not really for you but
you know there's a lot of violence and
you know you don't really I'm not gonna
just relax and tell you what I'm
thinking cuz you're a nice person you
live in a nice world the world you see
is a nice place with good people with
good intentions and that's not how I see
the world okay so I'm happy that you
exist and and I'm not trying to dissuade
you or teach you anything right god
bless you for seeing things that way we
need people like you more than we need
people like me and I don't want I don't
want to you know what I mean I just go
through your head every time
yeah and so when I
day that the whole crew on that film was
together um it was a wonderful moment
were Steven Spielberg thanked us all and
told us how great we were and then we
went to a restaurant where everybody was
talking and enjoying the experience we
just had and I got to hang out with
Meryl and I had a great time and totally
relaxed and just laughing and were you
upset with yourself that that's no
because she's cynical and so like it's
like I was right yeah right like I knew
like oh I mean obviously I should be
intimidated by her a massive talent and
resume and just who she is right but way
less because I could just I could say
anything and not feel like she might not
understand the point of view that I'm
talking from it might hurt her feelings
even to here are ruder or harsh comment
it wouldn't she's really a sharp kind of
harsh harsh person I mean she's very
close friends with Carrie Fisher and so
that feel those things right away and
you can do you can relax or the person
you think it has to do with Fame is my
point
I think the nervousness comes about a
feeling of like where I I already
holidays are the same wavelength and I'm
not trying to teach anybody anything I'm
I'm fine with talking to people who
understand what I'm saying and then you
know I'm not trying to lecture people or
so get in the way when Spielberg walks
in a room you're not going he does that
guy's so huge that he's like an icon and
when he talks to you it's like Abraham
Lincoln jumping off the penny and
talking you know like what are you
talking to me for you you should be in a
history book I can't look at you and
like how do you act take just was
freaking me out but that was everybody
was freaked out by that but everybody on
frodan Kirk take one your scene should
work he'll birds watching yeah it's
behind but you have to tell me a story
about being intimidated always go my
story my life even like I want
I used wood well I hadn't met you years
ago and I didn't see so long you've had
all this fame and all this you know and
I love it cuz you're one of the good
guys and you I was a little nervous I
was like oh you know and then you have
an innate ability to sort of make people
feel comfortable which I also I'm not
not to brag but I have a gift like that
I like to make people feel good and
comfortable you immediately go in my
office you're like wow you know the sign
[ __ ] I wouldn't get it but I can
understand why you do yeah and it's just
like there's a rapport you let you make
people feel comfortable that's nice to
hear well it's it's true but I think
part of that is you know if you get some
great roles as you've had and I've had
and you you get attention you kind of
ask yourself like how much of this
should I own and should I make a part of
myself like the attention you're feeding
me and the the focus I deserve and I
should you know and some people feel and
current incredibly justified and in fact
I think feel like they finally found
their place in the world when they get
all that focus and attention and then
they carry that with them wherever they
go
right yeah and then I think people like
me and I would say probably you feel
like well no wait I'm just a regular
person I'm getting attention because of
the project I'm in right now
whatever that is a movie weird on a
promotional tour or someone's a fan of
the project they don't know me right
they're not a fan of me they will never
know me my wife knows me and my kids
kind of know me and then that's about it
and everyone else who thinks I'm great
or wants to talk to me or give me their
focus they're fans of the project that I
meant
not me and and so I'm okay I'm just the
working person who's in that project and
it's nice to get that reflected
attention and focus it is nice
interesting nice but you know there's a
difference I think you know I want to
get into this but like there's I've used
this example before but there's a
difference between like getting
attention people telling you you're
great and how you fill up it feels like
it's like what equivalent to what love
is
right but love is sustainable and then
the
tension isn't alright keeps coming in
and ality Kongos right so if your bank
at all on that my therapist says because
it's not about you it's about your
projects and when your projects recede
in time as they all will in do ya then
you lose some of that focus and you're
like where is it where is it oh it was
never for you it was for the projects
right I'll make another one and if it's
good you'll you'll also see more of that
stuff sure we caught up though Geoffrey
get caught up knowing I was too old to
get caught a big success yes
so you really have like I look right you
know I just look like kids when they
were around eight or nine I remember
saying to my daughter I have the perfect
amount of Fame because occasionally a
person of mr. show fan usually would see
me and get smiley and asked for my
autograph and just tell me how much they
loved my work and it was like not every
day but depends where I was right
Jerry's deli yesterday you know somebody
would ya come out of the woodwork and it
was just really fun and I could even say
that / if you took a roomful of people I
could go that person knows me and that
person and they have mr. Schober neck
but but you know you just know and
that's it
now with Breaking Bad and all that stuff
then that was another level and
I
see how it would mess up a young person
right if you were 26 and you were in a
show that big you would I was 26 and
small but tell me about it
tell me about it you hear the doorbell
Bob hear the doorbell
that's all right doorbell 0km so tell me
about what my success or how it happened
being young and having that experience
because as an older person you've seen
friends go through it I was a writer at
Saturday Night Live and uh and we were
like weirdly this is such a the
self-hating cynical part of me
whenever I'd see a friend an
acquaintance have like massive fame it
would not so much make me think oh my
friend has achieved something great it
would make me think Oh anybody can be
famous now because if they know me and I
know them and they're famous and then it
doesn't make sense and they're well you
said something a little while ago and I
and I feel like I've just never felt
like I
I belong necessarily like I I know I've
had Fame I know I've had some great
roles I know that I've done well but
there's part of me that like a lot of
times I just don't feel I feel like I'm
still that kid from Indiana who's just
trying to make everybody laugh I'm in
Indiana southern Indiana I know you went
to SIU my buddy Ethan said go Salukis
yeah yeah so he went there so I got a
throat yeah and I know Indiana a little
bit cuz my cousins lived in Indianapolis
and then my brother Phil lives in
Indianapolis and where'd you grow up and
Nader an a perv --all millinery mostly
Naperville yeah mm-hmm but I would
occasionally go down to Indianapolis and
even to Southern I went once I don't
even remember who but I was like in high
school and a friend of mine I was like
we're going down to my uncle's pig farm
in southern Illinois is is it
Bloomington Bloomington Indiana
Bloomington Indiana I mean yeah and we
went there and spent the weekend oh yeah
we got the little five right
I don't know the little five Indiana
University is in Bloomington they have
the little fun under the bike grace do
they have a farm hockey team I'm sure
they do this city had a farm league
hockey team professional a farm league
you know trim away or something sure was
in Columbus Indiana I might have been
Columbus yeah in Columbus yeah and I
went to see the game it was great anyway
so Indiana is where I grew up but yeah
great I love that part of the country
and I love that strip of of weather and
all down here yeah four seasons man it's
[ __ ] great Carbondale a talking Karl
a bit of snow but now it just melts the
next day do you have good memories of
growing up like in the Midwest and
Midwest right uh yeah I was very mixed
but yeah pretty good I'd say I mean I
mean if my dad wasn't a piece of [ __ ] I
wouldn't real I would have been crazy
cuz I read about that you always knew he
wasn't he didn't beat us that's good and
but he beat you with his words nah he
was just remote and and [ __ ] up and
not around and and the tension and the
tension emanating from that relationship
and that his his what was missing you
know it seeped through everything in our
lives and we had a great I love my
brothers and sisters and we got along
great and we loved each other and
supported each other and laughed a lot
and still do still are very close and
I'm from a family of seven kids
but the tension coming out of that
feeling of like what the hell is going
on what was it was the argumentative of
everybody it was money and it was also
just he wasn't around like just now I
have seven but there's seven kids in the
1507 of you and you guys took care of
each other yeah yeah but like how do you
even have seven kids you have to show up
seven times they have to be at least
seven nights seven moments Kay musters
twin six but outside of those seven
visits I don't know how much you know
the guy was not to be seen never
remember him playing ball with you you
don't know where you did you remember
those not much yeah we even gave me some
advice once or twice that
that was close advice crying doesn't
change anything goes crying you know
what no he's right this crime not to
change no but because of the war
oh no uh no I think it's just from just
being a guy and older you do a little
bit boy what happened to me
in the last two years I'm like really I
get emotional I get emotional I mean
with yeah I don't know what it is in it
but it feels good it feels good when
you're alone to let out a cry and it
does it feels good to be emotional to
feel like you
you have access to your emotions well
the last time you got emotional hmm I'd
have to think about it for longer than
the podcast wants to wait but it wasn't
that long ago I mean I I alone I
breakdown alone or with whoa oh no what
was it I'll give you my I mean I broke
down at the end of Judy Mele gee really
yeah I just lost it I think there's a
bunch that was a weird movie cuz I did
not think the filmmaking was great it
wasn't a great movie with cheese oh good
that's what it was holy and that all
stuff after 47 years old you saw what
she went through she died at 47 and it
was from pills and just I don't know
what it was it's just a combination of
just you know there's been some pill
poppers in my family oh yeah yeah and
just like right you know last year I
went to this well in the center and it
was just I don't know it just
and it was on New Year's Eve I was just
with my dogs I didn't want to go out I
just sat at home no reason other I
wasn't really depressed I just watched
Judy I think my dad said it's really
good and then I put Judy on on New
Year's Eve at about like nine o'clock
smoke a little J and just Ball State
University just freakin unloaded with
tears I mean it was an ugly cry was the
ugliest cry of down no one should see
that cry that's a cry that would one me
an Oscar or a Razzie it wasn't good
funny right go either way you could go
either way have you had those breakdowns
where you just break the hell down and
then you're just like you laugh at
yourself because what are you doing
you're being dramatic
Bob I don't know I don't know if I've
had that but not for a long time but
yeah well you seem grounded though
you're a grounded guy I could tell my
yeah you're mature I don't think I've
ever been mature I think that's I'm
responsible but I'm not the most mature
really yeah can you not look around you
everything's autographed it's pretty
cool I love that jerk pose oh yeah you
know why go Joe would you work on I
worked in a movie club bringing down the
house I wear this horrible would cuz I
was bald from Smallville but I remember
day one talk about making you feel good
and comfortable yeah you have the
ability to do
Steve just comes up to me Gus so tell me
about this Smallville Wow and I go wow
you know the second weekend said I
brought him like a big thing of VHS
tapes because that's what oh yeah yeah
just go thank you
like he's good yeah and then at the last
day of filming I wrapped and by the way
at lunch you come over and he goes blows
anyone sitting here I don't know you
could sit with me he was just a great
guy in the last day I said hey man could
you sign my jerk poster it's an original
I don't he's like of course coming to my
trailer at lunch went in there he's
playing some banjo sign my jerk poster
fantast I'll always have that right
right that's the best yeah so you
wouldn't do that you'd be like hey great
working with you Steve yeah I wouldn't
sign anything yeah I'm gonna get you by
the end of this podcast to say there's
one guy you might owe know that's a real
good question
years ago I would have said Woody Allen
would be the one person that wants to
sign some and what movie oh gee so many
probably Zelig though really that favor
it's just kind of it's become my
favorite over time now what if you met
him what would you say I'd say hey yeah
like you're gonna get into it just weird
man unacceptable you know I don't how do
you know how to feel about that mess I
don't know what a mess it's just a mess
it is a mess any way you turn somebody's
devastated rights it's that's absolutely
true you just stay away from that yeah I
can't do a goddamn thing about it and I
certainly can't know what happened
exactly right and so it's very hard you
know but just creepy and awful and I
just feel bad for every single person
who helped yeah how do we get into this
conversation you asked me I you know
that's weird I really realized that
pretty quickly when I got a job as a
writer on SNL I was 25 and I remember
thinking
I should are this gonna be amazing I'm
gonna be around these celebrities
somehow that hadn't occurred to me until
I got there and then right away I was
like oh I don't care I don't care about
any of these people really you know what
I did I did have a guitar and I did get
it signed by Neil Young Keith Richards
and he still has its Costello wages
yeah see that's that's cool that's cool
because you know comedians and writers
love musicians musicians love comedian
right right right
yeah who's the biggest comedian out
there that loves you that you're like me
yeah David Cross crime yeah I don't know
I don't you know I was thinking about
those older is proud of the work that we
did I missed her show I know that a lot
of young people who saw it it kind of
inspired them and I'm I'm I understand
why we worked really hard that it was
ahead of its time for sure in a lot of
ways it was ahead of its time and we
tried to really care about the writing
and and the structure of pieces and and
really do a kind of a pure justjust
solid strong comedy and and and I think
people care about that for a few years
in their lives and as they grow up and
and if they go into showbiz and
certainly comedy but anyway I think what
was I saying no no I feel great about
that that we did it and that people
understand it and like it on that level
I just I'm just curious how people like
you know people is good how did you get
out of Indiana how did you I wasn't
popular I was a smallest kid in high
school I didn't know what I was you see
comedians in cars getting coffee do you
watch that I have seen it yeah there's a
great moment that I've thought about a
lot in regards to exactly what I think
we're talking about okay it's Garry
Shandling oh yeah I think I did see it
yeah and they're walking through the
lobby of the comedy store and and
they're looking at their faces you know
the the headshots from years ago and
yeah look at this and this guy remember
this guy
and then Gary goes in there I am I mean
that was says something like it's such a
big deal to get on here I died me just
me a kid from Arizona and then Jerry
like goes what like laughs at I'm like
what do you mean kid from Arizona we're
all from somewhere what does that even
mean and it's so interesting to see I
think most people are in the Gary
Shandling category of like figuring hell
am i I'm from nowhere and then people
like Seinfeld like that is that is a
special brain of chemicals that goes
well [ __ ] yeah I should be world famous
why not anybody well you got to come
from somewhere it doesn't mean anything
Wow right yeah great about it it's
definitely enviable um because it means
that he didn't hold himself back from
dreaming big you know he also seems to
have a real strong sense of what he can
do and what he does well and what he
doesn't do well but most of all it's
that great thing of like this guy has no
chemical in his brain ever telling him
that he might suck do you think that's
just what you're born with or do you
think you could be you could get that is
a Seinfeld sort of that I think you're
kind of born with it or you can like
achieve that like I just want where I
don't care I belong here I want to fight
I want to get to that point well sir
there's people who feel I think most
people are some mix of like feeling like
they don't deserve the attention and
then fighting so hard to compensate for
that and to argue against it that they
put themselves out there and put
themselves out there and desperately
grab and reach for more attention and to
stay in the the public eye and the
person who is just naturally accepting
and of their biggest dream and just
pursues it because of course you should
pursue that that's my dream
like it doesn't question that or a
question there
that validity of that dream they want
that's amazing that's chemicals in the
brain that is nothing else that is not
earned you can't make that happen the
person who doesn't have that has to wake
up and meditate and tell themselves
remember you're a human being you can do
something in the world and it's okay
it's okay to have attention from people
and they have to [ __ ] make themselves
believe that and I don't know whatever
you have is what you have I I think you
made me think I was thinking about
college now and I think I was there was
a fearlessness in me back then there was
a sort of once it connected once I grew
I was actually 511 6 feet tall went from
5 to smallest kid in my school
really to then being here 5-2 and what
what you senior year 5 to 5 3 smalls kid
couldn't get incomplete you know my
brother Phil also grew late later in
life and I said he had back problems -
no back problems but he it was hard from
cuz he loves soccer but he did grow in
high school and and he did play through
the whole thing right but but he was
very not not very big physically until
it's his story to tell it well mine was
like a year like the next year I grew so
I started to be like oh wow
girls are sort of interested in me so
this thing happened but I remember once
I found that thing and I was like
they're like oh you're good at this and
once I started going and getting that
confidence which was hard and I was
always in fight or flight I think I've
been in fight or fight my whole life
yeah my whole life once I hit this place
then they go I remember I go maybe I
should go to grad school and study more
theater or my remember my mentor goes
you're ready go to New York I go wow wow
and I'm telling you people were like do
you know the odds of making it I the way
I was programmed I go doesn't matter
I'm gonna make it I remember not caring
when they said those numbers like fact
can't wait I can't wait to I know what's
gonna happen I remember saying to my
friend Alexis combs I said Alexis we're
sitting there on the porch I go I'm
gonna make it this is but here's what
the change is coming I'm gonna tell you
the change because it's not
I said I'm like I'm you knew at the time
I knew that there will be podcast there
will be a podcast and I will it will be
I said to her I said I'm going to New
York and I'm gonna make it and it's
gonna happen pretty fast I know it just
remember this conversation I remember
saying remember this conversation
this isn't me dreaming this isn't me
being full of [ __ ] I just know it and
then I went and I busted my ass but a
little while you know I always busted my
ass but think things started happening
well within like two years three years
boom out to LA and then yeah all your
friend and go [ __ ] you if she's only
$100 yeah she listen we actually did I
never said you wouldn't what [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you no yeah I didn't say no to that
when you said that let's lose weight you
looked at me
[ __ ] you you owe me I don't know what I
was getting at but she we actually were
texting cuz she was listening to the
podcast and she's like Rosie I didn't
know all these things about you and how
you you know you have these issues and
and then she's just text me like two
days ago it's what I'm talking about her
but I went anyway long story short get
me out to LA doing movies TV and all of
a sudden I hit around 40 and it's not I
don't know what it is but everything's
changing now the one thing that's
changed is that you actually did it and
that and you did it a lot
you got into cool shows and movies and
you did them and you did more of them
and more of them and that's that's where
you start to that's where rich people
there's always rich people talking about
meditation and Buddhism and [ __ ] they're
like so wealthy and I know I know but
the point is tell me the people in the
Midwest are like yeah [ __ ] you got
nothing to do all day so you could sit
on your hands and stare into space but
the but the what's really going on is is
well they got everything they wanted a
lot of it and they started to realize
like oh well I still feel crazy and nuts
and nothing makes me I'm still not very
happy and so then they have to look
somewhere else for
and that's all it's really happening
right but like I'm but but you but it's
great to achieve it is a wonderful thing
to dream of something and want it and
then actually get to experience oh my
god is the greatest like it but it will
leave you feeling like oh what it's
actually not enough it's great and I'm
thankful but obviously that actually I
thought that was gonna be all that I
wanted but it's actually not but I'm
gonna fill you up an awful lot it I
really can and if you're smart you'll
accept it and be thankful and oh yes and
and and you have some perspective on it
this what I'm trying to say I am
incredibly grateful and really becoming
the man I've always wanted to be or not
sure well as you're looking at me how
dare you when I'm talking about
something so profound
yeah no I'm kidding but I think III am
NOT I don't have better call Saul money
I don't have breaking bad money I don't
have DeNiro my I'm not that guy I'm not
like that
you have a nice I have a nice house I'm
fine I'm very grateful but I'm not like
what you said would I know but what does
that even know what I'm trying to say is
that oh why is this is this it's okay if
this is just enough this is more than
enough yes
even though I said I'm gonna go do this
but but to actually be sitting in having
a house yeah but being said there are a
lot of other there issues you're not
really done I'm not remotely done but
I'm really trying to find that next
chapter because sometimes you do things
because oh that's my money maker may
myrrh that's my money may mermaid my
money where people just say well you're
good you should do that you're a just
like no dude you should be doing this
and like okay and you do what other
people say and you kind of yeah and you
mean but then where do you kind of go
hey I just you know I just want to keep
doing finding out what really makes me
tick I don't want to go back to all
right
you store stand stay in the course for
for what what you really want or what
maybe you're really destined to be and I
don't know what that is I don't know if
that if I want to really do acting as
much saying that you had a big therapy
on are you saying you had a big
I think it's great I love it are you
saying that you had a big dream and then
you're wondering if another dream can
come in that as is as big and can drive
you as hard yes and I'm also saying
because it is that dream really what I
really wanted deep down know now that
I'm finding myself and who I really am
obviously I'm grateful for all of it but
I'm like well is this what you really
love to love to do I mean you know or is
there some like helping people I in the
last year I've hands-on I've been just
doing more charity yeah look you and I
go to food on foot yeah just one of the
best organizations I think around for
homelessness in and you know I love it
and I love going there on Sundays and I
love being a club member yeah guys go to
food on foot org it's amazing you'll
learn all about it but you know I love
going to the ROM donal house I love
doing these things they make me feel
like I have purpose like I'm you know
I'm going in some kid who just wants to
live who wants to have this life and
I've talked about this ad nauseam but
just to make him smile just to make him
forget about his life for a while or
problems and to be there and to like you
know I'm going sat tomorrow I'm taking a
two-hour drive to go visit my buddy
Preston he's got cancer and you know I'm
gonna hang with his family for the night
and I'm like I'm excited about that I
get a little emotional thinking about it
yeah and like that's awesome doesn't
mean I can't you know but like I like
doing the podcast I like doing charity I
like if it's the right thing I like
acting like writing I just I'm still
trying to find me like shambling that's
what made me go oh my God look Aries
spent so many years searching for I mean
yeah who he was and what motivated him
and whether it was good or something
better and gosh he struggled he did do
you struggle or do you like hey man
you've got it like you've you know you
got the wife you got the kids you got
the success and you get be pretty like
hey I'm happy I get it gosh everybody
struggles don't think what do you
struggle with though
balancing balancing work with your
family balancing it and and asking
yourself why [ __ ] what can I do to I
mean we're all obsessed with the news
and one aspect of that is you you want
to make the world a better place you
won't want to make it better tomorrow
what we do what we do about these
problems and so there's a natural
inclination some people would probably
say that the last thing you should be
looking at is the news I know cuz all it
does is present problems to you that you
cannot fix in any direct way but what do
I struggle with
it's gotta be somebody I have a prior
temper all right I have a temper right
yeah I punched the printer today
that's so funny my buddy last night
punched his printer I sorta got he just
Paulie eight months ago as he goes this
[ __ ] thing ain't broke you just hit
it Ferb it just doesn't work when it
doesn't want to literally this is how I
work this [ __ ] printer that's only a
year old it doesn't print I go over to
it I press every button eight times that
I just press them all and then I wait
and then it prints and then today it
wouldn't do it even though I pressed
every first time you hit it
no I yes I was first time I punched they
feel bad no I mean part of me was like
[ __ ] you I get to hit you if you won't
work right did anyone hear you hit the
printer no well the dog did but the dog
was so mad at me what would she say what
would she say me so she would look at me
like what you've lost your mind
yeah you're dangerous printers this
machine I can hit it
[ __ ] it I bought it I can between you
and me this is between me and the
printer but of course that kind of rage
is you know I do it's not okay it's what
do you mean it's not okay so I'm gonna
hit a printer it's not really okay to
hit a printer but it's especially not
okay to do it in front of other people
right you don't have cuz then you're
involving them anything you do it
frightened comfortable involves other
people right and there's if you're on
the [ __ ] phone talking loud I mean
your conversation I get to talk that's
my theory on standing next to some
[ __ ] who's like how that [ __ ] her to
[ __ ] off and then he say to a guy I'm
playing when he's sitting behind you
like I don't know if I want to tell him
that let's talk about this you say that
I would if it went on long enough I
would and I have to be careful cuz I am
kind of famous yeah so but I still think
about myself as not famous so I think
[ __ ] that guy he's involved me in his
conversation I can hear what he's saying
he clearly wants me to hear it he can
me standing right here people to know
that I should pitch in how I should piss
yeah oh no I'm part of the conversation
you done cluded me and that's kind of
isn't that the case I mean if I do
anything big enough loud enough in front
of you I'm not what if you say your
difference didn't you turn around in
your in your seat in the row to a it's
an aisle and you look at him and you say
hey I'm not here yeah I'm here right and
then he goes to [ __ ] you then what do
you do yeah that's the problem don't
include me
just pretend [ __ ] you means done I'm not
gonna tell that's him saying [ __ ] you
I'm gonna tell him you're here that's
right you know it scares me is like not
scares me but I get nervous watching it
when I watch you I feel like your parts
so difficult because you're always on
your toes playing saw and playing it's
just like you have so many lines I do
and that always scares me as an actor
yeah oh it's good you always talk about
lines on this podcast yeah yes because
especially you are an artist the first
time and Breaking Bad when you first got
those four episodes you couldn't do the
fourth one because you had something you
had how I met you how I Met Your Mother
and then the fourth one they hired Mike
yeah a job Jonathan to do that story
right created that character created
that character so he owes you ten
percent of his money or so no him what
I'm saying is the first thing you said
in this interview I saw but you never
finished it you go and they had all
these lines and I'm like oh they're
gonna cut him because it's comedy or
whatever did they didn't cut him they
didn't cut a [ __ ] thing they cut one
word they didn't cut they changed one
word
they literally I was like I wasn't even
gonna memorize it because you know
comedy I mean comedy gets cut down and
to nothing or to you know it's what you
need that's it and
I also hadn't read it closely enough to
see what was going on and all that
dialogue I kind of summarized it in my
head like he's telling them I'll be your
lawyer and I'm a liar and all this [ __ ]
and you could just cut it down to those
lines you know and then I got the
rewrites I got the blue pages which was
about four days before we were shooting
and how much dialogue was this uh I'd
say it was a good solid two pages two
pages of dialogue maybe it was a page
and a half solid but you weren't nervous
I was a little nervous you are nervous
yeah that's a lot it was more dialog and
that was just one there was more than
that but at one point there was a page
and a half run of just me talking and
you always have here my biggest fear as
I go faster faster not even used to
seeing that in comedy I vote rarely seen
a comedy script that was one person
talking for a patient yeah but it's
usually back and forth and and stuff so
so one word was changed and I dug in and
and I had no tools to learn that except
what I think what I learned from writing
which is to break it down to the story
at the the core of it that I'm telling
and the bullet points of that and then
build back out from there do you write
the lines down does it help you memorize
do so you'll say on the page now I've
done this for a couple years now and I'm
better at it and one thing that's true
and I think see what you think about
this but usually about two weeks into a
season that my brain just starts getting
better at this it's just a bit of a
muscle in your brain and you got
yourself a break you do it the better
you quicker you get out you kind of
amazing
so the first episode give yourself a
break you might be the hardest one right
and then once you get going it's gonna
get better yeah it's gonna get easier
yeah a lot of confidence in myself to do
this now but on one side of the one side
of the script is the specific words and
phrases doing you know the highlighting
points as I go the things that I think
matter and on this other side of the
script is the emotions and maybe the
subtext highlighting points mean like
like words like a word that sticks out
as I go oh like that really stand out to
me that give me those breaks or that
that memory clicks yeah and the other
side is the undercurrent of emotion or
thrust of what I'm saying
the kind of more general Drive of this
[ __ ] you over yeah and and a lot of
times Saul in particular a scene with
salt is he's conning someone so his
words are a diversion in some weird way
or a kind of a subterfuge and on the
right side OB you know what that
subterfuges is actually meant to do you
know and and that and then and then it's
just work it you don't record it is a
record the other person's side so you
could deliver and give a space and yeah
yeah yeah yeah and I'm pretty good at
that I do that in the car or just in the
car cuz I mean if I'm driving it's it's
distracting yeah but we do a lot of
rehearsal on Saul and in fact Wow in
Albuquerque the cast we share a house I
heard about that
and who is every work Rhea seehorn
Patrick Fabian when he's in town um Josh
Fadem isn't your house that you bought
yeah my wife and I bought a house but
before that we rented a house together
the three of us ray and Patrick and I've
never heard of that that people want
carefully the last thing people want to
do when they work together I when I did
Smallville when I do other shows I love
them I'm on set with him all day I'm
like I love you [ __ ] off well yeah I
mean they're doing home with these
people
I know but no it's better than being
alone out there I think we all feel that
way that's my whole life pretty great at
leaving each other alone too
you know and and we're not in every
scene together and and I leave drama I
come home as much as possible so yeah
you know what I love getting home and
somebody's Patrick especially will make
dinner for everybody and energy there's
an urge I'm going hi
let's go because you know what if you're
alone Bob you're probably getting your
head a little won't ya
yeah I would get my head I go home alone
I'm alone what am I gonna do maybe I
should learn him on lines maybe she do
this
it's almost pressure you're like
worrying too much now yeah yeah energy
someone's cooking someone's watching
this yeah oh yeah there's coming that's
why I don't like being alone I always
like people around well that's good this
is perfectly fine I think you should be
able to be alone yeah I can see that
hole as long as I'm cleaning or yeah
organizing I'm pretty good at being
alone oh yeah uh-huh
how long can you be alone a long time
not with a printer I was a stab me I was
a little bloated yeah one of us won't
walk out of there
I tell me this tell me that Vince
Gilligan when they write the lines that
those are the lines they don't change
ammonia uh I try not to change a single
word I mean changing your dialogue when
you're about to shoot oh yeah they don't
change it see that's a blessing
there's nothing worse than go on have a
learn about this I've never experienced
it I saw people [ __ ] up I can't do it I
just can't do it this it's crazy to me
shows where they show up on the day of
shooting and go throw out that scene
here's a new scene no no we don't do
anything remotely like that we have the
scene in stone five days before
sometimes three days before but often
times a week and a half before and when
do you rehearse on the day oh no we were
hearse all leading up to yes you were
for two weeks I guess
as soon as we have a script I want it we
start rehearsing if I have a big scene
Esther Singh that day if it's two weeks
away I live in a house with Patrick and
Ray and Josh maybe and mando comes over
and banks will even come over and you
run it and and we run the scene scene
that I'm in or maybe I'll run a scene
with you that you're and we rehearse the
[ __ ] out of that show and then if I can
I'll go to the [ __ ] set when they're
not there walk around it and I'll do the
scene dude I love that is that sort of
what I would probably that's I've done
that right
is because we only have nine days to
shoot an episode and to shoot that kind
of dialogue heavy show 50 pages 55 pages
yeah in nine days you can't do it if
people show up and don't know their
lines and the other reason we need to
learn our lines is they matter like
literally there will be some little
weird thing buried in the middle of your
line that looks like nothing but then
poignant a year later is like remember
when he said this small thing that's why
I killed you know like every word almost
every word occasionally I'll call them
especially if there's comedy with my
character sometimes has scenes that are
almost pure comedy and then they have a
lot of flexibility there they also give
me a lot of room to move they'll come
they'll come to them and go this is
clearly a funny thing can I do this in
this and that'll give me a lot of
freedom most of what's written in better
call Saul and it was true of Breaking
Bad is like like no no that's that word
for a reasons there's the other word
doesn't work because you don't know
because three weeks from now you're
gonna give a script and you'll see that
because he said it that way it shows
that he doesn't really know who he's
talking to and he doesn't really know
what's going on and if you said it the
other way then it wouldn't be the same
meaning and so they've thought about
every way ahead of time now but you said
you need the time to learn lines but
you're talking about rear Herzing two
weeks before an episode but aren't you
going right into another episode even
even at the end of the season when they
get backed up on writing
you're still going you're still gonna
get that script five days five days but
you're still shooting the other ones
yeah
so during the day when you already knows
that you'll run it yeah you'll do that
you'll get out you're exhausted you're
working all the time you're exhausted
you're working have you ever hit a wall
where you're like yes okay curse season
in the first season well first of all I
was in every scene except for one
episode I wasn't in at all but in every
other thing I was in every scene it was
[ __ ] nuts did you complain I listen I
approach this whole thing like oh I
guess I'll just have more lines it's the
same job back
I'm not gonna pretend it's different and
well I was deluding myself a little bit
compartmentalizing and deluding myself
but then you know it was just a [ __ ]
load of words and I just dug in and got
to it and got to it and gave it up my
all and they kept pushing my call and
people don't know what that means but
pushing is if you has to wake up at 8:00
like we know they're working later in
the night so the next day they push it
from 8:00 to 9:00 a.m. to 10:00 a.m. and
they just kept pushing my call like and
and they we also say well you basically
means you're not getting enough sleep
and you also don't have time to rehearse
which I said we do and I was used to
doing for Breaking Bad and wanted to
carry on and better right and they're
doing 12-hour days to 12-hour 14-hour
days you're 12 around turn around called
the 12 like a turnaround sometimes they
say hey do you mind if we force you so
the crew doesn't have to do that they
would say do you mind if we force you do
my before she'd you mind if we force you
and I would sign it every time I I was
so thankful that we were making this
show and I didn't want anyone to have
any problem because of me yeah yeah you
know I'll just work harder I would kept
asking the ad like can I can I say no
because they would always say this was
the real shitty thing is they would
never say you don't have to do this they
didn't know they would always say hey we
need you to we need to force your call
so we didn't we need to do it for though
blah blah blah and then they'd look at
me and I'd be like well no compassion
well not like okay you need we'll do it
I guess
like you know say what they wouldn't I
know they won't never present it to me
that way it was like we need to and it's
like I think you're just informing me of
what you need to do right let me ask you
by if I would have said right you don't
have to tell me that even why do you
even have to tell me that the way you're
talking is so weird you don't have to
tell me that just give me the sheet that
says I have to wake up earlier and then
a couple weeks into that and I was
getting really fatigued and I lost my
voice and
and I was like can I are you asking me
are you telling me
and even when I'd say that question they
would go well it's just that we can't
make they wouldn't answer the question
it was driving me [ __ ] crazy I've
seen that yeah and then finally I found
an ad this is like week six or seven an
episode like five where they were gonna
force the weekend call that's the only
time to rest like in other words we were
shooting until around 7:00 a.m. on
Saturday morning right Friday in the
society 70 and 70 at like 6:00 p.m. we
shot until Saturday at 7:00 a.m. so you
really have barely a day and then Monday
we start at 5:30 a.m. I hope you fire
this first ad so we need to force your
call the weekend call you can't have
your 36 hours that's when you put your
foot down that was the point where I
said can I say no and this person looked
at me and said I think the crew would
really appreciate it if she said no Wow
cuz the crews died into their [ __ ]
diet they're [ __ ] slave and I think
I'm an [ __ ] you're saying yes to this
over over and over and over and I'm like
I thought I had to say is you didn't
even offer to me as a question and so I
said well [ __ ] know then and then I
got on top of it from that point on us
oh okay hold on a second and then that
same next week
you know the job of a producer in this
business is to shoot as much as possible
in as little time as possible the labor
users to save money so that's their job
they're doing their job if your back is
against the wall right and they are
doing their job but if you can't do a
good job because they've jammed too much
in then they're not doing their job oh
so they got to find that line right yeah
and these producers had not yet found
that line so it was a Monday I shot my
stuff I looked at my script I had
already had a couple conversations where
I said you guys have to give me time to
to do these things well to learn him I'm
gonna give give it my all but you got to
give me time and I looked at my script
and I had 30 pages of dialogue
for the next four days and you didn't
know it and you know Saul talks if I
have a page of dialogue with Jimmy
McGill Saul he's talking for three
quarters of that page it's not just a
normal character who might have two
lines on a page he has five lines or
five breaks and in 15 lines or more
ivory every page anxiety it talks a lot
how did you have an anxiety attack I did
I was all [ __ ] up I was all [ __ ] up
I didn't even realize it you know we
were talking about dogs out here oh my
god that first year I was shootin Saul I
got home and my wife and daughter had
picked out a [ __ ] awesome dog that I
love so much named olive and I just
spent the next four months every day all
day hanging around with that dog saved
you it saved me I had no idea what dogs
do for you can do for you and you can
read about it I know I don't like
Studies on it [ __ ] but oh my god I was
with that dog all the time after that
first season and still I do hang out
with her all I can but oh my god she she
just was like medicine you know for the
the degree of stress and kind of tension
that I kind of made my way through my
dog Blanche
so every time I'm writing and I'm up at
night late yeah she'll she won't take
she won't have it after a while she will
jump on me with her paws and you look at
this cute little face and it completely
saves me I just hug her and take ten or
fifteen minutes to just hang out and go
you're right what am i doing yeah you're
my life writing I'd be like I get mad
[ __ ] I hit something my dog will
run right over to me and put her paws up
what is it what I'm like I'm not mad at
you I'm not I'm just mad at my brain
it's not don't worry it's okay
no it's okay but yeah
I did have like yeah you know I want to
ask you this did things just quickly did
things get better when you became a
successor like all right here's the deal
I'm not getting forced I want a week off
every three weeks to kind of regroup you
know what's weird
it's like the overcompensation went the
other way on the part of the producers
they would just be so freaked out and
now we're at a place where I go like do
you guys need to force my call cuz it's
okay I really I'm rested up yeah I I
hear I owe you know you overhear them
talking about [ __ ] we're getting late
and how we gonna make tomorrow and like
I'll be like well I don't need I can get
here in time don't worry and I so now
it's gotten to the other side where just
ask me and I'll tell you honestly don't
be afraid to ask me but also when I say
no just say okay thanks for know
whatever now it's so dumb actors future
actors that's the whole last half hour
is only for you I'm sorry for everyone
else
now do the impression of Mike jet with
Jonathan banks do an impression of him
being asked to divorce call can't do it
what do you mean we need to do absorb
[ __ ] you actually he'd probably say yes
because he'd [ __ ] but then he'd say yes
because he can do it because he's just a
[ __ ] tank you can just listen that
guy he can do he's just one of these
guys one of these great lifetime actors
who's just spent his whole life acting
the [ __ ] out of every 10 meter and him
too I give him direction could you meet
well they should be because he'll bite
you down he will have you seen it
Oh many times have you ever said hey
Jonathan yeah that's the way it's coming
out like you know he I know [ __ ] get
it right
cuz he's rushed her to himself that's
what I said god what's the [ __ ] thing
but also oh he has less
of purity towards the lines than I do
now
partly that might be because his
character is kind of more
straightforward than saw so a lot of
times my lines are written in a weird
circuitous way that on the surface maybe
it just needs to be said that weird way
right whereas his lines you could change
him up a little and it wouldn't change
anything he's telling people to [ __ ] off
and there's the way it's good I'm not
doing this matter whatever yeah he sees
he's a straightforward character and you
know there's it's not as hard to change
those lines a bit you're colorblind I am
oh my I I don't I don't know blue green
orange [ __ ] like yeah were you the same
kid see I didn't find out cuz I failed
our class I got paddled I was called
dumb I thought I just had a learning
disability which I probably did but I
didn't find out till a freshman era of
high school and I was mr. anyone's
biology class and dusky right out
sitting next to me and I go hey turn to
page 78 if you don't see a sailboat in
the number nine and the circles calm
come up to class Ricardo Blount dusk at
I don't see you Michael Rosen mom's
colorblind [ __ ] [ __ ] tell her what's
the what does it matter well I didn't
know I thought I mean to me as a child a
fourteen-year-old boy yeah
colorblind no I thought it was kind of
neat like oh my gosh I have this is a
learning disability something's wrong
and now colorblind I had a hair on my
balls but I don't know it's embarrassing
when you don't know course I didn't feel
that way my dad I remember we're getting
tired it was neat because I thought it
was neat that you looked at the thing
like god I can't see it that's so weird
that's kind of amazing do you when you
see a traffic light right mm-hmm
what's the bottom one you know it's
green but what do you see what's not
yes it's white right yes it's like yes
people understand that
it's white but how green is it I mean I
guess my poor my question would be is it
really green
grass slightly green I know grass is
supposed to be an orangey blue is that I
know this guy's blue I can't dress
myself my assistant Jess is like you
know that's purple Mike doesn't that's
blue I can't dress myself because I
don't care enough to pay attention but
if I do pay attention I do okay okay
still not great you question the costume
designer sometimes I if I'm going to an
event I will sometimes put something
together Oh every time and I will go to
my wife or somebody who's there and say
how's this is this okay and I'll get
some why my publicity person is very
helpful and that way and I'll bring an
option to wear if it's like a talk say
we always have options yeah cuz they
might go what what are you doing you
think you're doing my shoes I don't know
with like oh can I wear brown with that
I don't yes it all looks okay to me I
wear things and she's like oh my god
what do you know does it ever feel weird
to you the degree to which you can be an
outrageous dresser so for instance if
you know who Billy Porter is yeah he's
on pose no no wrong Porter hi Billy
Porter yeah Krieger Ryan welcome to the
conversation no it was it was the
Grammys who wear that hat with the
blinds on it
yeah really is a great actor and a
really nice person I got to do an
interview scenario with him and he's
just awesome
I mean he's you got to get him in here
he's [ __ ] great yeah and he's got
stories cuz sucks success came to him
later and he earned it so hard and and
just a great guy really likeable person
and what we say about colorblind there's
something I'm just saying I'm asking you
because we're talking about getting
dressed for [ __ ] and like like you and I
bland as hell right but Jean but the
fact is we couldn't do that not just
because we have no sense of it but like
if you were let's say you had a PR
person who's
like we're gonna make you're gonna get
your picture and variety at the at the
Emmys this year because we're gonna
dress you so that it's worth [ __ ]
printing okay if you were a black tuxedo
there's no point in putting that picture
in the paper it's your [ __ ] head which
we've seen right and a black tuxedo
which we've all seen so there's no point
in publishing your picture there's
nothing about it you can just list that
your name that you were there and we
know what that would look like right
right but let's see your publicist said
to you you're gonna wear a dress men are
wearing dresses now true you know wear a
dress the big crazy hat you couldn't do
it because no one would go oh that's
cool Wow look what he wore he really
made us it he really made an entrance
they'd be like what the [ __ ] are you
even though they don't really know you
well enough to decide that that doesn't
mean anything to you in the same way it
might mean something to Billy or anyone
else right right yeah you know it's fine
what's that about
I don't know what's going on I don't
know and I did I just I just can't
compete with that I think it's a subject
for a Curb Your Enthusiasm I think we
found a good I think that would which
you were on a plot for for Larry David
uh-huh you know the about four months
ago they did some article on me and then
they go hey and they I came there and he
had this suit and it was like tweet and
likes just different colors and I know
and I did this will really look good no
look yeah you look great so I said [ __ ]
it
I'll do it yeah and I took pictures of
me I couldn't believe I posted a picture
of me in the school suit for the first
time dude you [ __ ] need to dress like
this all the time people look great yeah
I can't wear suits every day I can't
yeah like that every day it's just I'm
so comfortable in app look at me I don't
know what the hell this is here's what I
think
comforting here's what I think go ahead
think we are lazy now we don't really
give a [ __ ] not about that
right right why shouldn't we do make a
little effort we don't need to go as far
as Billy but why don't we just go
the nicer shirt costs three times what
our shirt costs but we can afford that
before we can afford it so [ __ ] your
pictures being taken
put something on that's cool to look at
for me for the audience I grow the
people agree but what I would need is to
for somebody to tell you it actually I
would say I need you to put Monday
through Sunday from socks and underwear
to shoes and everything together
automatically it's just there I'm gonna
go take it off the round where it not
worth it because Garanimals grranimals
do you remember that no you don't
remember do remember what our animals I
was actually in the eighties it was like
a thing where it was closed for little
kids where Garanimals their you know had
a shirt that had a little zebra on the
tag then you you wore it with a song
I don't know that you wore it with pants
that also had a zebra on the tag and
then you knew they went together there's
got to be a song song they gotta bring
that back Garanimals or middle-aged
white guys Garanimals you think I work
well I think you and I'd be great
spokesman for it I think so I need a
sponsor I got to get into this because I
thought I was gonna talk to you about
this more Chris Farley my favorite
comedian of all time no one makes me
laugh I will argue to anybody people go
oh Belushi this I I don't think you put
Farley in the same room as any of these
guys there's nobody that makes me laugh
as hard as possible with almost
everything he does and the best [ __ ]
thing and nobody probably knows this
except if you're in the industry is you
created motivational speaker map for
actually a lot of people know well thank
you well no I think a lot of people in
the industry know it heard about a lot
and I and I okay look the truth is I am
really proud of it because I did write
it pretty much exactly the way he
performed it and I wrote it alone in my
apartment in Chicago and Chris had done
a version of the character in an improv
like the night before
but none of the story of the script or
not nothing none of that [ __ ] was in
there you know he'd seen a version of
the character and that and it's such a
performance heavy thing so I'll share
credit on inventing the thing because he
did that a version of that character and
that inspired my brain so your brain
wrote you created that well the story of
it the scenario it was all me lives in a
van down by this guy I mean he would it
was the greatest thing I ever was a part
of I think just pure simple one thing my
daughter once asked me what's the best
thing you ever did and I said doing that
writing that scene and doing it eight
times a week it's at second city because
like you I feel like there was nothing
greater than seeing Chris be funny and
act and and I was onstage with him
because I played the dad and scene and
so to have him do that right in front of
you every night and by the way different
every night a little different every
night every single night he would not
quit until he made you laugh until he
made everyone on stage laugh and the
audience came along and boy I'll never
forget it was the greatest thing and
when it was happening you're like this
is the greatest thing I've ever I'll
ever do yeah even you know I'm glad you
said that because I think it's like if
I'm in a bad mood I know that I put that
best of SNL Chris Farley on uh-huh and I
watch the motivational speaker I watch
and I memorize that whole thing I you
know I was like I am a skinny Farley I
would and I got a chance to hang I was
good friends with Kevin and Johnny I
guess I got to really you know and I was
just went when he passed I was just as
many but I write about him a lot in my
memoir which is coming out and about
a year and a half and it comes back
right before comes out sure yes
[Laughter]
yeah I I did I write about him a lot
what is it what is that you write what
is it that you is is it emotional when
you write it well some of it is I don't
know some of its kind of sad and I don't
know how you felt about it but you say
you knew or you got to be with them a
bit well I mean I got to hang out with
him a couple times with the you know
those guys and spend some time but it
was always funny and laughing and
drinking it wasn't you know I know that
the demons and I know from his brothers
and I know you know I think the hardest
part for me was just we just my father
was an alcoholic and I learned a lot
about alcoholism when I was young
because my mom took me to al-anon which
is a great thing to attend if you have
an alcoholic in your family family
members of people with alcoholism can
meet and talk about the things they're
going through and the hardest part was
how just how inevitable it all felt
everything in Chris's story the way it
played out you just knew well people
talked about it for years and years this
is gonna happen than that and then this
and then that and then that's what
happened did you ever tell [ __ ] hated
it it made me so mad because the one
thing you don't want your life to be is
a cliche you don't wanna you just right
I mean that's me yeah that's what I say
but that's what how I feel now I want to
do something that surprises me and you
about everything about the choices I
make really surprises and and and not
just live some [ __ ] boring over told
story that has that's just a hackneyed
cliche and his [ __ ] story just played
out like somebody could have written it
when he was 25 just horrible it was it
just like this feeling of like I mean he
could have written it he could he just
didn't love himself ultimately
for sure III first I can relate to that
I think that a lot of people can relate
to a lot people can relate you know and
so what do you do you act out you try to
be funny you try to do this everybody
loves me
and like we were talking about earlier
it's like how a good say yeah I I think
his brother wrote a great book about him
you know that that book what's the book
about Chris his brother wrote not I am
it's great and if you have a family
member who's alcoholic the book about
Chris is really good to read because um
while in in general terms it was a
cliche journey and that really pissed me
off more than anything in specifics you
know there was a lot of struggle that
went on and and there were moments that
looked like he would be alright what's
the name of the book is it the Chris
Farley show a biography yeah the Chris
Farley show yeah and and you get to some
of the ins and outs but Chris had some
moments where he might have pulled it
off he might have gotten out of that did
he ever come to you for help or the um
no he never came to me for help no um I
did see him at a party once in Hollywood
not drunk and not drinking he was with
Spade and it was at somebody's [ __ ]
apartment I don't even know who was like
jam-packed with people and other than
made you happy and I couldn't believe it
I was like Chris you're not drinking
nope and he meant it and he was strong
and he looked great like you know look
in his eye and strengthen I was like
holy [ __ ] this is [ __ ] great he's
gonna [ __ ] make it
yeah whatever he'd been to rehab you
know seven times so by then and what
what it finally clicked good great and
that's the guy I think everybody was
rooting for pull it together
yeah really only saw that one time that
was the only time you remembers the only
time I ever saw the look in his eye but
at least I saw it once and it gave me
hope but other than that you either got
him [ __ ] up or him in that other mode
of like I'm the [ __ ] idiot
I like this is a show this is stop stop
you [ __ ] putting on a show for me
it's weird you're standing right there
I'm not in an audience I'm I'm a person
don't [ __ ] put on a play for me right
and and it was just Oh gross yeah and
that's those are that's all you got and
and it was sad as [ __ ] because he was
such a good person and his goodness and
his heart and a great I came out and in
everything he he did and and you just
could it was palpable you know you could
just feel it you know do you ever get
like you said she did comedy your whole
life you liked doing you always in
comedy writing sketches yes and now
you're doing Conan you go by the way my
buddy Harlan I told your heart your
Harlan City just came up to me after
performing Harlan Williams you know Dumb
and Dumber my buddy so ready boys nobody
saw it but anyway he went up to him and
you're like hey you want to be in Conan
O'Brien he's hey yeah sure but and you
got him on Conan O'Brien you're that guy
though that that doesn't happen I think
some of my friends still think that
happens where you know somebody just
will walk up maybe in their apartment
while they're like yeah it's doing
nothing saying well you know um I love
to do that you know see somebody and see
someplace that where they could show
what they do something great I'm try to
help make that happen sometimes it
happens sometimes it doesn't but I've
been lucky enough to pull it off a few
times yeah but you can't help yourself
right you go like I know where this
person should be and you know it's a
tough business and if you can give
somebody a shortcut either advice or
just a connection to make you should do
it it's [ __ ] hard as [ __ ] and a lot
of really talented people to some extent
they're just waiting in line I mean you
just kind of wait just keep doing what
you're doing yeah you're just in line
they'll get to you and but if you can
shorten that line you should try to do
it when do you say you're too old when
do you say maybe you don't have what it
takes maybe do you ever say that you
just have to let them figure that out I
think that the big big key is
if the thing itself is still satisfying
to you
look you can always want for more you
know but if sometimes you meet actors
and they clearly are sick of acting like
pissed off about it about making an
effort or showing up it was like well
just go do something else I mean if the
thing itself is not making you happy
that's that's the math you have to do as
far as like am I too old mammal I make
it well I still get more get what I
deserve huh are you happy when you go to
set are you excited about the day yeah I
have an amazing job I have the best I
can't imagine a better acting job than
better call Saul I mean there's no I
have a page that's pure comedy and then
two pages later is intense personal
drama very well written really a you
know a the character has matured which
has been just the greatest thing ever
there is a scene in the last week's
episode of better call Saul that's
silent I mean there's like what there's
like four lines but it's me and and Ray
as Kim and it's mostly silent and it's
just it's there K there will never be I
can't imagine a role that's as good as
what I have so I have to just be very
thankful that I get to do it do you are
you surprised if you looked at like
14-year old Bob Odenkirk and freaking
Illinois or whatever yeah there's that
Garry Shandling thing again that yeah
yeah I'm Arizona who the hell a moment
I'm thinking is not even everybody in
Hollywood's from somewhere the [ __ ] does
that mean hey I'm a Jerry's right in
that instance but I relate to Gary
of course I most Jerry most developers
right that's what he's Jerry but what
but what I'm saying is you always for a
long time thought comedy I'm always
gonna do comedy well the thing and
that's funny because you were talking
about I'm gonna be big one day I'm gonna
make it I never said that to anyone
never but I
so didn't in this you may have some
shared feelings on this but I never
thought about it that way I just didn't
I knew I wanted to make enough money to
pay the bills when I was 21 and I
decided to try to do this I said if I
haven't made enough money to you know
eat and have an apartment doing this by
the time I'm 30 then I'm gonna look for
something else to do but I have until
I'm 30 I'm gonna give myself nine years
where it's not about making it I'm just
gonna do what I'm just gonna focus on
the work what I love which I love to do
and and then secondarily if I make
enough money and I'm 30 then I'll stay
in the business if I don't then I will
then that's the rule I have to look at
it and look for something else well are
you surprised that you have become this
phenomenal dramatic actor from from like
a comedy writer and comedy actor who was
doing did you ever honestly think one
day I'm gonna get Critics Choice Awards
not no of course I didn't think that not
at all but here's what I did think and I
talked about this in my book - the one
time I was on stage with Chris Chris
Farley and Jill Talley at Second City so
I was a couple years into my comedy
career I was I'd already been a writer
at Saturday Night Live for three years
and and we were doing an improv and you
know how when you do a show a lot like
on stage it's I could sit here on stage
eight times a week eight shows a week
your brain can really like you can think
about what you have to buy at the
grocery store you can think about
something you have to do tomorrow you
really can go you can kind of
compartmentalize what you're doing
because you spend soul hours on stage
right and I don't know this stray
thought came into my head that like I
should try to do drama
one day I'm on stage doing a scene and
it's improv by the way like we're making
it I better pay attention but I just had
this weird thought I'm looking at the
audience and they're looking at Farley
and I don't blame him I would be too and
I'm like if I was in a drama what would
that feel I'd be pretty [ __ ] great
how old were you I'd have been about 27
so you thought it was that mom or I
could and what it was was it was like a
thought of I think I boil it down to
like comedy has um I think comedy this
is my [ __ ] theory you guys ready
comedy 101 it goes goes ooh this is a
comedy 104 - OH
305 you're a junior in college now
studying comedy okay
the [ __ ] theory is that comedy is
kind of appreciative and rewarding of
simple energy like Chris you just love
him you smile the second he walks in
front of you I think a lot of comedy
actors have this quality I think Will
Ferrell I think Sandler although Sandler
can get complicated this thing he did
last year is amazing
other Netflix special I know the movie
with the safdie brothers uncut gems
the best performance of the I do that
was the hardest performance to me when I
watched it I I tweeted he liked it but I
tweeted him and I said this is the moat
I hear when I watch her perform yeah I
think sometimes as an act you sit there
can I do that yeah you know what I could
do that I could do it my own way and I
could be great at that right he's great
I'm not knocking it and there are some
performances ago I can't do that I
couldn't do it I just dad that was
Sandler's performance yeah couldn't do
that yeah I agree
me too and yours my girl is going to
that same kind of character I don't even
want that guy it's so hard in a wide
ways it's built from me yes it is you
know but Ally I think comedy kind of
rewards a simple simpler energy that you
bring where the audience the person
watching can kind of know that person
quickly like that and I think drama
rewards a certain degree of compliment
complication where the person where
you're like I don't know if this guy's a
good guy or bad guy I don't know I think
he's being funny but and I think that I
probably bring more of that kind of
energy in front of people and just from
doing a lot of comedy and being around
people like David Cross who's so funny
and Jay Johnston and and Chris and Jack
Black and people who are just you just
smile when you see him and you just
laugh and to mention some women Jill
Talley and Marilyn rice Cobb although
she can do drama - it turns out but I I
just had this weird brain fart that I
think I'm I think I fit maybe in this
other world maybe I might better I never
pursued it I got my point and that's the
weird part
right and precise I did audition for
roles if they were offered to me to
audition for right I auditioned for a
couple Alexander Payne roles and and of
course Larry Sanders kind of rode this
line between comedy and drama but I
never pursued it right because because
the life of an actor is so [ __ ] hard
and you really are you really can't do
your job
unless someone says you can do your job
unless you get in an Acting Company and
you guys put on plays and you decide
what plays you're gonna put on and you
put yourself in them you don't get to
decide if you get to act and that always
looked like a sucky scenario to me where
as a writer can't make people buy your
[ __ ] but you can just do your [ __ ]
job for free right take out the paper
and go to work and if it's good enough
you can hope that over time you'll sell
it but at least you get to do it at the
very least you get to do it and no one
can stop you and it's as close to
writing as a successful person it's the
same job as a person who's successful
you're you sit down with the paper and
you try to clarify and and and deliver
drama or comedy or whatever it is you're
doing and you get to do your [ __ ] job
without having to ask somebody
is it okay for me to do my job today
would you let me and that so I never
pursued acting because of that aspect of
it because I just the idea of having to
get permission just no [ __ ] way I'm
going down that road I love it
this is that this we're gonna finish up
at this is what I call my patreon they
have the patrons have it's called [ __ ]
talk with Rosa mom these are just
questions from fans real quick he answer
him quickly you'll have to like linger
on it real quick bob says can you name a
childish thing you still find enjoyment
in throwing a baseball is herb riding a
bike I love riding a bike makes you feel
young again
I love it Robert would you ever consider
attending different Comic Cons as a
guest from meat and grease with fans as
well as fans of better call Saul on
Breaking Bad I don't think I would I
don't think really yeah why is that not
your thing
it's just not my thing all right don't
perceive it as a meaningful thing to do
but what if fans all over the world who
never could meet you can meet you what
good is that gonna do them they're gonna
love it worthless they're like oh my god
waste but not to them but be a waste I
go to these conventions I'm just gonna
say you I'm not saying you're not
knocking it yeah I get that you're
saying it's not for you I'm saying when
I go people all over the world or
whatever they get to meet you look any
hangout I always give up go above and
beyond I think it's a great thing for
other I enjoy and they enjoy I hear ya I
hear ya there's nothing wrong with it I
saw you know a person whose work I like
John Cleese I saw he was doing a tour
and you know he just talks about his
career you know I saw a lot of some
older actors I think Pacino did this too
that's great
I mean I would want to go see Pacino
talk about his career and and Cleese too
you know so I see the value of it I just
I guess for now I'd say I don't really
think I would do it alright amy was
there ever a character you play that
you're really connected with
yeah Bend bag Dickian in the post I felt
like he was a lot like me and I Anna and
I got to know some people later who knew
Ben bag deke and the reporter who got
the Pentagon Papers and he sounded more
like me than I even knew so cool swore a
lot he got pissed off a lot he was
driven he was kind of a purist and and
yeah
Spielberg just knew you were the guy
well I guess so but I feel like I
connect to that guy more than anybody
I've played Emily what was it like to be
in the office I was a joy I mean listen
that to me that's the most fun kind of
acting a Curb Your Enthusiasm and the
office where you get to improvise around
a funny comedy idea and with a few lines
from the writers maybe a structure and
then you get to improvise just better
and it's kind of based in reality right
so you're sort of it's not super broad
then they say you got about make it like
three or four minutes we don't have a
lot of time here yeah you just do
multiple takes and then they give you
they give you advice on shortening it or
speeding it up but it's the most fun
have you done it have you haven't you
improvise a little yeah there's been
something like rosy going this one you
know just let you guys just start yeah
but I mean like a show like curb no I
don't do that one day it's the most fun
you can have doing this although second
or equal to that is um fighting in an
action movie is really fun you like to
fight I like getting physical
it's the most fun it's just for I'm just
saying it's super fun
you know I like action I like doing that
stuff but like a choreograph it you
learn it you get in good shape and then
it's a bunch of people all chipping in
there's always last-minute changes that
you have to make even though you
choreographed this thing and there's an
excitement to achieving it to doing the
moves and getting them right and like
it's hard to do and you have to work
together to do it and it's just a real
group effort it's it involves your brain
and you
body so it's everything here just
completely focused it's a it's a real
hoot I love it Raj from your time on SNL
do you remember writing any skit she
thought were hilarious but didn't make
it past the pitch meetings and
rehearsals uh
there was one really really dumb sketch
that I wrote and Jon Lovitz was for Jon
Lovitz and Lovitz always remembered it
too and he always brought it up to me I
don't I'm not guaranteeing it was good
but in my mind I thought it was pretty
good it was uh about a hot dog vendor in
it who has a trainee and he keeps
blowing up at the trainee like put
mustard on it what are you doing when
the person walks away well I don't know
yes from but you don't put it on right
away just give me and he's like the guy
who's training I miss trying to figure
out reasons why it's not so easy to do
when it's there's no there's nothing to
train like Mickey training Rocky but for
a hot it's like yeah you you handle this
this guy do it right this time and then
like it's earnest and he puts it on and
looks the guy gives it so and then the
guy walks away
you know I mean it's like it was kind of
pure performance which is great on
Saturday Night Live oh yeah and it was
really funny and uh and read-through but
I think that probably Lauren just
thought oh it's just extremely dumb how
many extremely let me talk about yeah
can I sleep in your bed please let me
sleep
come on yeah yeah Jerry can you tell us
a fun behind-the-scenes story from
either Breaking Bad or better cost all
that no one's heard a fun
behind-the-scenes I don't know something
if you think of it we will not have
nothing I'm sorry you know really this
is actually a problem for me is uh I I
work really hard and I I don't have all
I don't [ __ ] around a lot
like goof around no goof-ups Oh we'd
laugh and make jokes but we [ __ ] work
hard so I sometimes I hear these stories
about people on set and playing pranks
and stuff and you're like who has time
for pranks
we barely can shoot the show at the time
we've got if I [ __ ] pulled a prank
I'd be like Sony's on the line you blew
$50,000 with your [ __ ] prank what the
[ __ ] is going on you shoot the show
Jonathan banks somebody prank Sam
Frankie's going Kevin have there been
any story arcs that you suggested or
worked with the writers for better Kyle
saw the meeting the show get an idea
it's a good question I they do ask me
what I think and I do I do talk about
the show and the character pretty much
from the point of view of a fan which is
to say I just watch it and I I'd like to
see this happen and I like this
character and I want him to I don't want
him to die or whatever I just sound like
a fan when you read fan comments I'm the
same way don't kill Kim come on you know
they don't listen to me I mean they do
but they don't but they shouldn't
because they're great storytellers and
and they think on a deeper level and one
of the things they do is they're really
always working to tell a story that you
couldn't predict but that makes sense
emotional sense and so usually whatever
I pitch them is kind of some logical
extension of what's happening and that's
exactly what they don't want to do is
something that you can foresee fairly
easily they want to do something that
surprises you but resonates with
everything you know about the character
or the world
Lisa Annie get behind the scenes stories
from your time on How I Met Your Mother
another question that's not about how I
Met Your Mother that was amazing not a
story at all but I I did like six
episodes and the first time I went in
the read-through I was like is going on
like people hey how you doing what you
do where'd you go we went to Santa
Barbara
oh really did you eat at that place
every
was smiling and they read their script
and laughed and then they clapped at the
end of it and I was like what the [ __ ]
is going on who's is there somebody here
that you're doing a show for and then
the more I did the show the more I
realized no they like each other
they liked the show they're on and they
like each other that was so weird just
odd to you
it was so [ __ ] weird it's like I
couldn't conceive of it I'm not that
people hate each other but right
they were so um happy who's also people
get so jaded so easily in this business
right and they weren't they were like
really thankful to be doing this show
that could be obnoxious can it seem real
but it was but it was the more I would
go back the same thing would happen
again you wanna come but shouldn't you
feel that way I remembered I wish from a
Molly Sandler also kind of made me see
that in in the world that I kind of you
know you work so hard when you start now
and you're kind of looking for a break
and you know you're just kind of working
against like how much you suck you're
like I suck so much I gotta work so hard
and then to see him enjoy everything he
enjoyed being on Saturday Night Live he
enjoyed but after-party and the energy
of it and like what do you what is this
guy doing he's happy about this and then
you're like well I should be to [ __ ]
a come on if you can't enjoy this [ __ ]
some no that's kind of not right that's
true
and I think that a lot of people
everybody everybody I talked to you from
SNL or it just seems like it was
miserable arms its competition me
there's a lot of reasons why SNL is
miserable for people and number one
they're very young it's their first job
they're unbelievably intimidated they
feel like it's gonna be a judgment on
them I think a little less now than it
used to be it used to be when I went
there there was a feeling like if I fail
here I'm out of show business now people
know that's not actually true you can
Robert Downey did one year there right
but
you know it doesn't mean you suck
forever it just means it didn't work
there right and people kind of know that
and that's good that's healthy but you
know people are young and intimidated
and it's a [ __ ] steam train it
doesn't slow down for anybody so there's
nobody holding your hand nobody explains
to you what's gonna happen next
so it just is a it's a recipe for a huge
mindfuck and it works the last question
Danny was it a thrill to be a cast a
cast in the Larry Sanders Show what was
it like sure and likely what was it like
to work with Garry Shandling
it was a huge thrill to be a cast in
Garry show and I had been on the Ben
Stiller show before that and a writer
there and Gary had guested in the show
we all got to know him from that and and
just from the scene because he gave a
[ __ ] about young comics he watched
people and looked for who's doing
something interesting and he believed in
me which I didn't deserve and I don't
know why but I was thankful for it and
you know it was really nice to play I've
always enjoyed as I've had the
opportunity I love comedy
I write comedy I loved writing the crazy
broad comedy that I wrote when I was
young and I still like it but it's
really nice to play it's more subtle and
more real feeling characters I think for
me I can modulate in there better and I
can I just feel more effective in that
world so getting that break Gary giving
me that break to play somebody who's
just a little more straightforward human
it was awesome it was awesome I had this
great joy to be around him although he
was stressed out all the time Gary
really do you know Gary I did know
Garret I mean you know lean you know I'm
like five or six times and he was always
like he was want to know about yeah yeah
yeah right he was always like what are
you doing that that fari silverman
Sarasota's party i saw yeah we talked
for awhile
what is it would he eat on that show
what is that what did you like it what
do you what do you do it
what's the he's always picking my brain
and it was just but he I felt like he
just wanted to talk about you at least
that's what I know he did he
yeah I mean that documentary that judge
did for amazing for each of you right
now for Netflix was just great it's
really it's great but it is it is sad
and and it is also um you just get
exhausted do you do though all that
stuff do you meditate to you do you
believe I try to meditate with headspace
you know that app that's really good
yeah I maybe I don't do it every day but
I get into it more you work out a lot
you're in good shape I'm in good shape
leader 62 no I'm 57 oh good
but I will be 62 if all goes well no but
you look great my dad died at 56 56 you
know whatever your dad dies at that as a
guy I personally thought well I won't
make it to 56 for sure cuz I know oh
wait a minute I did the math wrong cuz
I'm I'm 40 I'll be 48 and you were born
in 61 yeah
my father didn't die Oh in fact if he's
listening to what the [ __ ] it's our hi
pops
doing dad no he didn't die anybody never
will he's healthy you say he doesn't
drink he doesn't well he doesn't do
anything huh never he never won he'll
pray up you know my grandfather lived
long it's you know I think it's pretty
good but yeah I didn't your dad died
mostly had bone cancer he had bone
cancer and I don't know how you get that
I don't either how do you get booty
smoked but he spent a lot of time in
bars where there was an awful lot of
smoke right right back then and uh hey
this is awesome joyeux this I did was
great having a great conversation but
wasn't that yeah I really had fun with
you then we can go in all different
directions and just talk [ __ ] I really
I'm thankful cuz I know how busy you are
and I know you're a family guy and I
know you work your ass off yeah and I
also try not to do too many podcasts cuz
there's so many of them and you feel
like enough about me right but you're so
interesting you're such a good
perspectives not sure how uh you know
Albie it's cynical yeah I am I am we're
great we'll go take a picture downstairs
yeah alright thank you it's been great I
hope you enjoyed that if you enjoyed
that please please subscribe if you like
buh buh Bob Odenkirk and that's the only
reason you listened I implore you
try to listen to some more you might
learn something you will learn something
from other guests and the guests that I
have they open up more than anyone will
ever see or know it's not entirely true
but they it's pretty phenomenal and I
love the support and I'd appreciate it
if you subscribed and send it to your
friends add inside a podcast at inside
of you pod I think on Twitter Facebook
is in Instagram is inside of podcast
Odenkirk is just so dynamic man I love
that dude man I hope everybody's doing
great I want to give a shout out to my
patrons they just keep piling up they
surprised me every day I seen your
patrons and I'm just I send them a
message of thanks and support for the
podcast top tier is Allison L Andrew see
Angelina G we just did a YouTube I do a
private YouTube for my patrons here and
there and I just play music for an hour
and a half and I talked to them and they
talked to me and it's nice and sound
it's sexual Barry I hi Barry
Bobby bull tax Brian H Carly asked Chris
cjp Emily K Emily s Hamza be jackass
Jacob Jason D Jason W Jennifer s Jerry W
Jill E
Joshua D Judith she's new shoot at D
judy judy judy
Catherine M Kevin are Kimberly Lauren G
Leah s hi how are you Stubbs mark a Mary
be Melissa our Mikey Nancy D neil w oh
yeah bro
Nico you know I love Mineko Nico so
helpful he's been really helping me in
the whole podcast stop just you know
just working hard on yeah on the inside
trying to get us uh more attention Raj
that buddy Raj ream ream Robert B rocks
raccoon
she's new but it's been here a little
bit Samantha M CeraVe Shaun W Stacy L
tabatha 272 Tiana Trisha
Vanessa in the sky and everybody you
Kiko I love you Kiko as you know your
support is tremendous you can go to the
online store inside of you online store
to get inside of you merch I've got a
bunch of great stuff and left on Laurel
stuff is still there too if you want it
won't be there too long much longer so
you might want to get some left on
Laurel could become a collector's
edition very special thanks to my guest
bob odenkirk special thanks to ryan
editing this it's hard to be away from
Ryan you know I'm doing the solo myself
and he's doing that all by himself
we're just just a lot here's a here's a
fan hey Michael I know I'm probably
supposed to join patron patreon and not
just email you directly but I haven't
had a chance to even look at patreon or
much of anything anyway just a quick
note to tell you whatever obstacles or
discouragements you run into keep going
I had a difficult week after years
almost 1,000 shots tens of thousands of
dollars in multiple miscarriages my wife
and I did our final IVF cycle an embryo
transfer everything seemed to go well
but our last baby a girl didn't make it
I feel like a dumbass because I had my
own I had my only child my two-year-old
daughter so excited as I had told her
her sister and his name Victoria was on
the way oh I probably shouldn't have
said anything to her but I was so
optimistic things are a bit tough now
besides my insurance lifetime fertility
coverage maxed out my marriage seems to
be in a rough patch I'm done with the
IVF stuff I can't do it anymore and just
want to focus on being thankful for what
I have my wife is older and resents that
I won't keep trying but even the doctor
says it's unlikely I can I keep tearing
my family apart chasing something sorry
for the novel of an email but I wanted
to tell you that I I got this tough news
and I was devastated scared of what
comes next filled with anxiety after
praying I went for a walk and your
podcast was one of the first places I
went it genuinely made me feel better
gave me more perspective
or some perspective so whatever you run
into keep doing what you do man because
it does matter and it makes a difference
thank you Rob well you gonna get me a
little choked up Rob um don't even know
what to say
what is that doesn't that just put
things into perspective talk about
perspective you'll have tough days we
all have stuff going on and then when
you read that you're like okay I love
when people reach out I love when they
are vulnerable level my guests are
vulnerable I like when people just are
human and they act human and maybe at
the end of the day when this is all over
we'll be more human more humane more
loving forgiving accepting you know not
being able to touch your friends and
give him a hug or just hang out and have
laughs you take things for granted and
I'm not preaching I'm just saying I'm
figuring this out
what you have what is important to you
what's important to you is right in
front of you and always will be it's not
those intangibles of you know you want
to be this you want to do that I want to
be a rock star I want to if I had this
bigger house if I had it's really I'm
telling it you've heard it from so many
people rich poor if you have love if you
have connection you have got it all
thank you all for allowing me to be
inside of you today and I hope to see
you next week
[Music]